REMEMBER BOOSTED?:
Remember Boosted Boards? They were a
premium electric skateboard company that was quite
popular back in the early 2010s largely thanks
to one influencer: Casey Neistat. Casey was an
avid user of Boosted Boards and used them to get
all around New York City. And given that he was
vlogging on a daily basis during this time period,
and getting millions of views on each and every
video, the amount of brand exposure he got for
Boosted was insane. All of sudden, Boosted was
the go to electric skateboard manufacturer for
millennials despite often costing over $1000 per
board. Pretty soon, Boosted started receiving even
more coverage from Marques Brownlee, a few viral
videos, and even traditional news outlets. For,
the longest time, it seemed that Boosted was
truly a humble grassroots success story that
fulfilled a specific niche, but things didn’t
stay that way forever. Moving into the late 2010s,
we started seeing viral stories pop up that
Boosted Boards were overheating and catching
fire. Boosted didn’t just try to sweep this
under the rug either. They publicly admitted
the issue and announced a recall of second
generation boards during the holiday season
of 2016, making it clear that they prioritized
consumer safety over maximizing profits. But,
despite their goodwill, they slowly faded into the
background as they resolved their issues and came
out with a new generation of boards. Just like
before, these boards would also be covered by
Casey and a slew of other popular creators,
but despite the social media coverage,
sales didn’t get all that much better for
Boosted. They tried to diversify their business,
but all of their efforts to expand outside
of just skateboards also fell flat. And as a
money burning VC backed startup, the only way
that Boosted was gonna survive was by showing
growth. And given that they didn’t have much
growth to show, investors would eventually pull
the plug on Boosted and Boosted would file
for bankruptcy in mid 2020. Looking back,
it seems that just one public misstep destroyed
the entire company, but really, the boards
catching fire were just the tip of the iceberg.
So, here’s what really happened to Boosted.
OPTIMISTIC BEGINNINGS:
Taking a look back,
the story of Boosted dates back to 2011 to a
couple of Stanford students named Sanjay Dastoor,
John Ullmen, and Matthew Tran. Like most
college students and urban dwellers in general,
a daily pain point for these guys was walking
around campus and nearby areas. Technically,
everything was super close within just a few
mile radius, but when you’re walking back and
forth between your apartment, classes, grocery
stores, and libraries, commuting time starts
to add up pretty quickly. The go to solution for
most people is to simply ride a bike, but our trio
wanted a smaller simpler solution that could be
easily carried around without compromising on
speed. Thus, the idea of an electric skateboard
was born. Our trio was by no means interested in
slapping a motor onto a skateboard and calling
it a day. They wanted to create an extremely
refined and reliable experience. So, they started
desigining a motorized skateboard from scratch,
constantly tweaking and improving each aspect
whether that be acceleration, breaking, handling,
or durability. Fortunately, they had plenty of
time and resources to do this as they had secured
backing from Stanford’s own startup accelerator:
StartX. Eventually, they would come up with an
extremely premium board that people would call
the “Apple of E-Boards”. And to guage just how
interested people would be about a Boosted Board,
the trio would launch a Kickstarter campaign with
a goal of raising $100,000. To their surprise,
they would hit the goal within just 1 day and
they would end up raising nearly half a million
dollars. By all accounts, this was a great
success, but reading between the lines, you could
already see a few red flags, primarily the number
of backers. Despite raising $467,000, Boosted only
had a total of 1,100 backers. The average backer
was putting up $420 meaning that to reach their
$100,000 goal, they only had to get 200 to 250
backers. Not a bad goal by any means but really
brings into question just how big the target
market really was. Nonetheless, Boosted would
continue with their marketing and go to market
effort. These guys were young guys who understood
the power of social media, and as such, much of
their efforts went into growing their Redit and
Facebook pages. Sanjay even hosted a Ted Talk
that would go viral pulling in nearly 2 million
views. All of this traction helped Boosted raise
another $10 million in funding but what happened
next was something that none of them could have
ever anticipated. Boosted had caught the attention
of up and coming YouTube star Casey Neistat who
would single handedly boost interest in Boosted
by a whopping 300%. This trend would simply go
into overdrive when a creator named Jesse posted
a video viral video of him riding a boosted board
around New York City that was made to look like
the magic carpet from Aladdin. This video would
go on to reach 35 million views. Jesse would make
a follow up to this video in San Francisco that
went on to get 13 million views. And that was just
on Jesse’s channel itself. It’s very likely that
with all the reposts and media coverage, this
little stunt drew the attention of over 100
million people. Boosted could not have dreamed
of a more successful brand awareness campaign,
but Boosted would soon learn that brand awareness
and sales were 2 completely different things.
HURDLE AFTER HURDLE:
None of this is to say that
Boosted didn’t have a roaring start. Just due to
the raw magnitude of exposure that they enjoyed,
they obviously sold a bunch of boards,
though we don’t know the exact number. But,
once all of the hype settled down, Boosted was
left with a much trickier situation. The reality
was that the original problem that they were
trying to solve did not even benefit from their
invention. Here’s the thing, commuting on college
campuses is surely a hurdle for college students,
but you know what’s an even bigger hurdle?
Spending $400 to $500 or even over a $1000
on a skateboard. So, aside from a few rich kids,
Boosted had largely boxed themselves out of the
college market simply due to price. And this is
really a shame given that most college students
probably knew about boosted thanks to social media
and many of them probably even wanted one, but the
price was simply too big to swallow. Fortunately,
Boosted also appealed to urban dwellers as well,
but the same issue largely applied. Those who
walked everywhere usually couldn’t afford a
premium electric skateboard especially with the
rents and general cost of living in these cities.
And those who could afford it weren’t exactly
the kind to be riding these around the city. I
mean could you imagine an investment banker or
corporate lawyer riding one of these to work on
a regular basis. So really, Boosted Boards only
appealed to exception cases like Casey: high
income earners who regularly traversed the city.
This isn’t to say YouTubers like Casey and Marques
were capping and that Boosted Boards weren’t great
products. They were phenomenal products, but just
because you have a phenomenal product doesn't mean
that it’ll sell. It’s the same issue that Lucid is
facing right now. By all accounts, they’ve made a
car that tops not just Tesla but the EV industry
in general in virtually every category. A lot of
people would love to have this car, but with that
being said, there’s just not all that many people
who can buy a $100,000 luxury electric sedan. It
was the same thing with Boosted, and things only
got worse as competitors started catching wind of
this trend, particularly Lime. If you’re not
familiar with Lime Scooter, they’re the guys
who started the whole electric scooter trend.
Basically, they were looking to do the exact
same thing as Boosted but with 2 key differences.
Instead of skateboards, it was scooters which is
a lot easier to ride for most people. And two,
instead of having consumers buy their scooters,
they had people rent their scooters. Generally, a
Lime scooter cost a $1 to a $1.50 to start riding
and then $0.15 to $0.39 per minute of riding
depending on the city. From the business side of
things, this was a terrible idea because achieving
profitability with this model was a nightmare. In
fact, a major competitor to Lime called Bird
just filed for bankruptcy last month after not
being able to make this model work. But, from the
consumer side, this model was great. They could
pay just a few bucks to get around the city on
the few occasions that they were in a rush or were
just feeling lazy which was a lot more affordable
than getting a Boosted Board. Now, you could
argue that these small transactions eventually
add up to being even more than the price of a
Boosted Board and you’re probably right. But, for
most consumers, it’s much easier to afford a $5
micro charge every time they ride over a $500
upfront cost. And just as Boosted was struggling
to find their core market and Lime entered the
scene, Boosted boards would start catching fire.
THE FIERY FALL:
The who fiasco with Boosted Boards catching
fire takes us back to late 2016 to a web developer
named Rick Bross, or actually more specifically,
his roomate. One day, when Rick was out, his
Boosted Board would start overheating and fill
his apartment with a bunch of toxic smoke which
naturally frightened his roommate. Instead of
vacating the apartment as soon as possible though,
the roommate would decide to record the incident,
which as you would guess would end up going viral
on Reddit. Given that Boosted would eventually
go bankrupt, it wouldn’t have been surprising
if Boosted had just pushed this under the rug
acted like it never happened, but Boosted did
the exact opposite, they did the right thing.
They reached out to Rick immediately, offered
a replacement, and wanted to take a look at the
defective board to fix the issue. Boosted’s CEO
Sanjay took it even one step further. He would fly
from California to New York just to meet up with
Rick in person and address the issue. Before they
could resolve the issue though, another report
about a defective Boosted Board would come out,
and this would pretty much force Boosted to issue
a full recall. It turned out that the issue was
that water was able to get into the battery
pack when riding which eventually caused a short
circuit. Boosted would of course fix the issue
and come out with a refined version but things
were never the same. As such, many publications
often point to the fire incident as being the
definitive end of Boosted but I’d argue that they
were already headed in that direction and that the
fire incident simply accelerated that trend. You
see, for Sanjay, electric skateboards was always
just an entry point into the electric market. His
end goal was always to build out a whole slew of
electric products like bikes and scooters, but
to his disappointment, these products never took
off. Sanjay was even willing to step to the side
and let another person have a shot at being CEO
and expanding Boosted, but this wasn’t all that
successful either. Well, actually technically,
they did continue to run decently successful
marketing campaigns and even partnered with
skateboarding legend, Tony Hawke, and even
almost Kanye West. But see, brand awareness
and marketing was never where Boosted fell short
anyway. They always crushed it from those aspects.
Where they truly fell short was product market
fit and profitability which remained a constant
throughout their run. And eventually in mid 2020,
they simply ran out of funding and had no choice
but to file for bankruptcy. They would sell off
the remaining parts of the busines to Lime and a
company who wanted to take on the Boosted
brand name. If you look up Boosted today,
these new owners are who show up, but these guys
have nothing to do with the original Boosted other
than the name. And that’s what happened to
Boosted Boards. Another product that blew up
in the 2010s only to fade into oblivion is
GoPro. Check out this video to learn more.